matches ich mag ich wirklich richtig
lässig ich nutze ich zwar nicht so lange
aber ich habe mich jetzt schon richtig
über herz geschlossen mag dich auch
nicht unglaublich geäußert ich mag dich
eines auch ganz gerne genutzt sich zwar
nicht so häufig wie snatch oder musical
die aber ich mag dich auf instagram
eigentlich mag ich ins land waren aber
in letzter zeit hast du mich echt schon
hart ab und in diesem video wollte ich
euch einfach mal erklären sodass du
hilfst an alle die instagram eventuell
nicht kennen sollten das ist ein bild
und video basierte social network bei
dem man sich eine count machen kann und
fotos und videos von sich oder von
irgendwelchen ereignissen hochladen kann
andere leute kommen dass leichen
kommentieren ich habe die schnauze ich
weiß gar nicht dass gerade erkläre war
eigentlich jeder instagram kennt
jedenfalls fenster für mich immer so die
plattform wo man etwas hochladen konnte
und es wurde wirklich von allen leuten
gesehen und jeder hat gesagt hey ja ich
hab das neue bild gesehen und ich hab
kommt hier nicht ausgelegt und es war
voll cool
das war übersichtlich und ganz ich hab
instagram täglich gelesen ich das selber
der instagram seite wird fast 300
geposteten beiträgen und einer million
abonnenten also können wir nicht sagen
dass ich die plattform nicht regelmäßig
nutzen und mitte 2012 was jetzt
tatsächlich auch schon vier jahre herab
facebook dann instagram aufgekauft und
da kann man halt so meldungen wie
beispielsweise fotodienst instagram
aufgekauft facebook geht shoppen
facebook und einem fotodienst instagram
für eine milliarde foto sharing facebook
kauft instagram habe ich mir erst mal
früher wirklich viel bei gedacht es hat
sich ja auch nicht viel verändert ich
meine es wird eigentlich alles erstmal
so weitergeführt wie es war wenn
facebook direkt was verändert hätte wäre
es natürlich auch blöd gewesen
change a running system doch in letzter
zeit habe ich wirklich vermehrt beiträge
von irgendwelchen instagram usern den
ich selber folge gesehen diese in die
richtung geht nochmal profil klingt oben
rechts auf die drei punkte und klickt
auf beitrags benachrichtigungen
aktivieren und ich selber hab mir erst
mal nur gedacht
das ist jetzt kenny mit kaufen will ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt posten doch die
letzten tage ist wenn wirklich
aufgefallen ist schon wichtig geworden
ich erkläre ich mal was ich genau meine
facebook hat vor einigen jahren diese
bezahlfunktion eingeführt weil es ist
bei facebook so beispielsweise ich habe
ihnen über 500 freunde und es ist nicht
möglich dass ich jeden beitrag wäre
irgendwas geleitet werden was
kommentiert abwägen was gepostet hat
ganz natürlich chronologisch
untereinander angezeigt bekommen das
wäre halt einfach zu viele sachen
deswegen hat es facebook so gemacht und
die idee dahinter ist ja eigentlich auch
gut war wirklich nur die sachen
angezeigt bekommt die wirklich auf einen
selbst zugeschnitten sind das heißt die
kennt ist locker selber wenn ihr gegen
die vier mit einem kumpel bei facebook
seite geschrieben habt ihr die ursachen
auf der facebook seite eingeblendet die
von ihm irgendwie sind also die er
geleitet hat kommentiert hat freunde
markiert oder irgendwie so und die idee
dahinter ist ja einfach nur dass man
mehr von den sachen sieht die ein
wirklich gefallen und weniger von den
dingen mit dem man sich eh nicht so viel
auseinandersetzt und viele fakten sicher
auch darüber ab dass man bei facebook
bezahlen muss damit sein eigener beitrag
gewinnen wird aber das hat mich alles
nicht so hart ab weil ich facebook nicht
mehr juckt also ich habe sondern eine
facebook seite habe ich bin darauf nicht
mehr aktiv aber jetzt wird sich das
ganze mal auf instagram dieses bild hier
habe ich genau vor fünf tagen
hochgeladen habe ich nämlich gedämmt
über dem berliner alexanderplatz und das
bild hat 80.000 lights dieses bild hier
zeigt nicht mit einem goldenen play
button und dieses bild habe ich am
dritten februar hochgeladen und deshalb
92.000 likes das ist ein halbes jahr her
natürlich können jetzt leute mit dem
argument ankommen und sagen ja luca
natürlich ist er sechs monate her und
natürlich müsste das eigentlich viel
weniger leicht haben aber der goldene
play button laufen ist doch ein tolles
ereignis in meinem leben gewesen
vielleicht deswegen mehr leute gleich
nein zu dem zeitpunkt februar hatte ich
die hälfte an followern die ich jetzt
habe ich kann euch das ganze wirklich
auf einem normalen bild zeigen und zwar
wenn das hier ich auf einem bild wo mir
sehr viele leute ihren mittelfinger ins
gesicht strecken und dieses bild hat
auch 81.000 leid und ist vom 24
februar zu diesem zeitpunkt hatte ich
540.000 follower auf ins kleinste ich
kann nicht mehr richtig rede was ich
euch einfach sagen will
dieses bild hier ist auf fünf tagen
hochgeladen worden 180000 leistung
dieses bild hier habe ich vor sechs
monaten geladen wo ich nur die halbe
anzahl an followern hatte die ich jetzt
gerade haben deshalb mehr likes und
dieses bild ja sogar noch mehr live und
es wurde noch früher hochgeladen ich
glaube ihr versteht so ein bisschen
worauf dieses video hier hinauslaufen
soll vor einem halben jahr hatte ich
eine halbe million follower auf meine
bilder haben so 80.000 likes gemacht
jetzt habe ich allerdings 1,1 millionen
verloren meine bilder machen ein noch
80.000 likes weil sie einfach nicht an
alle meine follower ausgespielt werden
ich bin weiß ich dass man anhand meines
wie ich bin die tage einfach mal durch
instagram gescrollt und hab dann dieses
bild vom eingedeckt hochgeladen vor 14
stunden damit ich dann weiter runter
geht es kreuz und sehe dann dieses bild
hier vor 4 stunden
warum ist es weiter unten ist neuer habe
ich ein weiter nach unten gescrollt das
hat dann dieses bild von den serien
entdeckt was vor zwölf schon hochgeladen
wurde haben wieder weiter nach unten
gescrollt und sehe dann ein bild vor 3
stunden
instagram wollt ihr mich verarschen ihr
seht ihr das nochmal dass ich dir
wirklich nach und nach ab fotografiert
habe und ihr seht schon ich kann euch
noch viel mehr beispiele zeigen ich habe
mir wirklich noch viel mehr
abfotografiert und wenn jetzt gegen
hater von euch sagen sollte lukan kannst
sie einfach in einer anderen reihenfolge
ab screenshot und cruise selber in dein
instagram und geht selber in euren feed
auf eure startseite und scrollt einfach
durch dann seht ihr auch bei den zeiten
die unter den bildern stehen das oben
beispielsweise im bild angezeigt wird
von zwei minuten dann drei minuten vor
10 minuten vor 15 minuten dann 14
stunden und dann noch einmal vor 3
stunden und dann wieder vor 14 stunden
wieder vor 10 stunden
es macht einfach keinen sinn instagram
wegen habe ich selbst auch ein bisschen
seine ehekrise mit instagram und wollte
euch deswegen wirklich einfach sagen
wenn ihr jedes
sehen wollte was ich hochladen dann geht
auf meinen instagram profil was sie
jetzt ja eingebildet klickt oben rechts
auf die drei punkte und wenn du darauf
gelegt dass ich das ganze so aus weil
dann steht da ganz unten beitrags
benachrichtigungen aktivieren und da
müsst ihr drauf klicken dann seht ihr
wirklich jeden post den ich irgendwie
hochladen das was ihr mit dem video
meine damen und herren sorry dass
darüber jetzt ein ganzes video gemacht
haben aber irgendwie fand es cool und
wollte euch das einfach mal so ein
bisschen zeigen wieso das mit instagram
gerade so ein bisschen bescheuert ist
alles wenn euch das video gefallen hat
würde ich mich über like freund
schreiben wir eure erfahrungen mit
sozialen netzwerken die kommentare und
mir leid kommt jetzt aus - doll warum
wie das euer freund versuchte lang hat
und ihr das gar nicht bewusst weil es
von instagram total geschockt vorne
sehen jetzt mal die eingeblendet wenn
ihr darauf könnt ihr mich abonnieren
wäre auf jeden fall schillig dann seht
ihr halt neue videos von mir und server
und hier findet ihr ein video namens
instagram bildern nach stellen weil das
ja auch mit instagram zu tun hat dass
milch verlegt euch das mal könnt ihr auf
jeden fall auch auf checklisten
schäbiges video geworden erfolgt noch
ins als der laser luca und haut rein
freunde
wir sehen uns